So why do we care about how far light can travel
in one nanosecond? If you know what kind of processor you
have, and if you have a Mac, you can find this
by selecting from the Apple menu, About this Mac. They'll be
instructions on the website how you can do this for other
operating systems. But you'll see a window like this appear that
will tell you what kind of processor you have. And if
you zoom that a little bit you can see that we have
a 2.7 GHZ Intel Core processor. What GHZ stands
for is gigahertz. Which means that we can do 2.7
billion cycles in each second. So that means the
time we have for one cycle. Is actually less than
a nanosecond, and you can think of a cycle
as the time that computer has to do one step.
So it does one step 2.7 billion times in
a second, that means the time for each cycle is
1 divided by 2.7 nanoseconds. So that means
in the time that computer has for one cycle,
light travels 11.1 centimeters. So how far is
that? So, let's have a little scale here. If
we have a dollar bill, that's actually quite
a bit longer than 11.1 centimeters. 11.1 centimeters is
about three quarters of the way across the bill.
So within the time light can travel that distance,
the computer's gotta finish processing one cycle,
finish at least part of an instruction. This
should give you some idea of how fast
the computer is operating, and this is part
of the reason the processor has to be so small. If the processor was bigger than
11 centimeters, we couldn't even send light across
the processor in the time for one cycle.